red prawn on sauteed avocado with
guacamole and black truffles Breton
Turbots with beet puree and horseradish
foam and a lemon dessert with grapefruit
blood orange and white chocolate they're
the creations of chef dick ho-bag he and
his dedicated young team at the aphelion
gourmet restaurant on lake constance
serve up menus that thrill both the
critics and ordinary diners alike Hobe
egg isn't primarily interested in
culinary experiments his cuisine is both
straightforward and refined if it is a
fearsome one the philosophy is to take a
product and show its many facets we
carve little stalks out of the leaves
later and put them on the blade they
have that full cauliflower taste and are
crispy or thin we cut the cauliflower
florets into thin slices which are then
roasted and we cook and puree everything
that's left the restaurant lies right on
lake constance with a stunning view of
the mountains
many of his vegetables like this lettuce
were grown on right in our island in
lake constance but he's not a chef who
uses only regional products this wild
turbot comes from France / Bex Maxim is
serve up the very best food that the
world has to offer doctor doctor I
always think that it comes down to the
product and the quality and not the
region what good is it for me to tell my
guests it's not tasty but it's regionals
then I'd rather say it a sensational and
comes from Canada that's our philosophy
at the aphelion
the restaurant in the hotel Riva is
named after the beautiful tragic heroine
a philia from Shakespeare's Hamlet and
the beauty of the surroundings was a
major reason why dear Coburg a former
student of star chef had heard wolf at
moved to Constance in 2010 after
travelling extensively Faubourg has put
down roots in this city on the border
with Switzerland he founded the
restaurants and met his partner here
and for almost a year Dec ho-bag has
been cooking for someone else beside the
Afilias patrons his daughter's summer
doctor
as her father are more worried about
whether everything's healthy rather than
good-looking I cook with lots of love
and tried to make something tasty the
thrills her every day she's not always
thrilled every day dia kohlberg takes
advantage of living so close to the lake
in the summer he swims and surfs here
and he jogs here whatever the weather
[Music]
I'm at the lake every day water is
energy it's just part of me I wouldn't
want to do without it
his workplace is also right by the lake
dear Quebec spends ten hours a day in
the kitchen cooking at the highest level
and his dedication has paid off testers
from the Michelin Guide awarded the
affiliate two of their coveted stars and
the German edition of restaurant guide
Romeo named dick Hauberg it's rising
star of 2018 some critics have even
stated that his highly elegant cuisine
with depth is the answer to the meaning
of life
but dear Kohlberg himself has less
philosophical aspirations he's aiming
for his third Michelin star yeah sure I
want to have it of course I'm an
ambitious person if there's a goal to be
reached then I want to reach it the
salkinds gonna happen but while he
reaches for the sky dick ho-bag can rely
on his family to keep him down to earth